so this guy again drop a comment if you
want to subscribe but it was the
emotions of that process were crazy and
scary the whole thing to go through it
and I remember winning it and the
emotions of winning it was crazy
competition so I've used it to invest in
a number of projects that we're doing a
normal yeah so we actually got the five
nice option apartments that we did as
part of the eviction so we're taking
them on as a joint venture group so in
the end when we actually did this part
the eviction they we were they were
pitched by the agent to us as a no money
down deal but actually you come to sign
the contracts and things look at about
12 grand to put into them it's not bad
so they give us they will give us and
we're still in a process to get them all
set up with a minute but they will give
us about five six hundred pound cash
flow per each so it's not bad so when
you have all winners Wednesday the last
time I remember the title something like
from zero to financially free in three
month yeah yeah are they doing fantastic
so my apartment in Sheffield still have
80% of lost occupancy rate with it we've
actually through that particular
apartment we were contacted by somebody
else in the same block recently who's
also got one in there they live abroad
they're not managing it very well so
they've asked us if we'll take it off
them on the rent to rent and that's
purely through the previous winners on a
Wednesday video and just how we market
our our apartment
so this they saw that they contacted me
said look we saw your car the part with
the shepherds
and they said yeah we saw the o'clock
when it's doing really well we've got
hours it's not performing really well
and we got a really good deal from one
so we're looking to take on in next
couple of weeks now so there the house
it took a little bit longer than we
wanted to to get rented the buyer versus
a lot of it comes down to is how we
manage the refurb and I'll be honest and
say we could have managed it better but
that's a learning curve isn't it this is
what we want in a long time we would
like to tennis our end they've been in
for three months now paying an
absolutely fine
lovely term it's really happy with them
so they pay for seventy five on that one
so make about two we manage that one
ourselves to make three twenty three so
yeah we've got no money into that one we
use an investor finance I mean every
single and I say this to people all the
time every single one of the deals that
I personally have done I've been a no
married down or none of my own money
into the deal yeah and so they are
possible you know they are it's about
building the right relationships so for
me no money down means none of my own
money into the deal now this for me
might mean that I've put it on a zero
percent credit card that I've got for
six months and I'm going to pay it back
using the profits from the property
because to me that still knows my own
money in the deal yeah and that's how we
do our apartment
I'm meeting do is like your lease option
agreement still you got five properties
you put that twelve that's it's not it's
not to do that you're a key right it's
all about just being creative there's a
solution to every problem and like you
say it's about having good problems and
bad problems I'd rather have a problem
where how am I going to find the
investment for this property then I'm
just not even going to entertain getting
into because there's no such thing as a
no money down deal yeah and like I said
we've done it with every single one
today there's moral stories people do
how can you continue to say it's not I
think the reality is it's that title
isn't it no money down and like you say
people don't want to believe that you
can't buy a property with no money and
the reality is you can't if there is
some money that goes in there but it
doesn't have to be yours it's about
being creative
you know and I think right when you
embrace that creative nurse you know
anything's possible
yeah okay so do flies live insourcing
about deals as well like on a deal since
also how many deals you sold sold an
awful lot I probably say 15 16 something
like that deals so they range the
minimum we sort of charge on a fee it's
probably about two and a half thousand
the maximum we charge for one that went
through is five thousand as a
development deal yeah James Armstrong
yeah yeah absolutely fantastic James
this phenomenal and he's very good at
deal sourcing and he sort of helps me
take my business to the next level
because I really like to get out there
and view the properties and look at how
the by refurbishing finance works
where's James is very investor focused
you know and he's built some amazing
investors so we brought a great
relationship together because he's
finding the investors I'm finding the
deals and it works your lesson so if you
remember people's names it's a lot
smaller than anything
I think I think there's a couple of
lessons that we've learned along the way
and one is when you joint venture with
people that relationship because when
you joint venture people you might think
you know the person and you might think
the relationship is gonna go really well
and even though you do know the person
it's about defining the roles that
you've got individually so our lease
option apartments in Derby I'll go
really well and we know they're going to
be extremely successful however there's
been a lot of teething problems along
the way because there's four of us
involved in it and everybody is equally
putting as much effort in but then
things get missed and just because we're
we're all very active people it's about
making sure that we individually define
roles yeah so now what we've done is you
take on that you take on that you take
on that and I think the second thing is
is we talked about having exit
strategies all the time with any kind of
property investment but we don't talk
about what happens contingency as you're
going through the process and I think
that's really important as well so like
I said my by refurbishing finance the
refurb went over a couple of months so
then in the meantime we're paying
council taxes were paying bills but
whereas these are all things that we
haven't factored in so that cost has to
come from somewhere yeah and it's about
understanding how we can solve them
problems because if you get landed with
you know if you miss a council tax bill
which is this that you know this is what
happened to us and we got landed with 12
months worth that counts of tax need
they're paying upfront then you've got a
you're backtracking we solved the
situation then we got we got relief
because it was empty whilst we refurb in
it but the point being is we could have
anticipated that
for seen that problem comment yeah if
we'd have looked at contingencies and
looked at things that may go wrong so I
think you talked a lot about best case
worst aches likely case and I think that
should have been in our worst case
scenario well because we didn't put it
in there we didn't look at that
we weren't prepared for it whatever I
need to do I'll always say what's the
worst case that you think I'm a negative
person I am the least of the birth of
the planning probably but when I do to
deal the way I do the calculations is
quite negative often on almost worthless
cases if we're still making money on all
the words of cases happening then we're
good to go and now then I'm always gonna
be surprised you know so that's that's
great
it would have certificates we should you
builders and so with my builders really
it's just because they've been working
on multiple jobs and one thing I've
noticed is when one thing falls back so
on the project what happened was one of
the the builders couldn't complete the
particular task they wanted to do so
that meant that had a knock-on effect on
everybody
which puts the then everything out by
two three four wheels plus so from a
refurb perspective that's a really
valuable lesson because you know
investor friends of the minute that
their refills ran over by three months
you know when you're looking at HMO
development and you build run over by
three months that's a lot of money that
you miss now on now you know
channel it just goes ahead you've gone
crazy
and when you started a year ago when
everyone did you come to deal for guns
were year ago September yeah okay so
pretty much so when you came to the
field for a year you ain't crazy and you
just went all those properties you are
the same but you know you're completely
broke I reach out to become karate for
seven days so ever you did that for real
I think with your job working in retail
did that for real with no money had no
knowledge when it's your own a draft to
pay for some training with myself and
you journey even when you ask people
when of Wednesday when you've been in
the business all wrong so you gonna be
able to me or fine actually free to a
bit of gray but now you just such a
reach because knowledge about property
you know it's incredible seeing where
you are now that's the way you work
Wednesday thank you
do you feel what I do and do you know
what I think the most important thing to
focus on is that I never focus on the
money aspect of it now I had a financial
freedom for vigor which was the goal I
needed to achieve so it's 1123 professor
yeah and you need that in three rooms
oh yeah ditch and how
so last month last month because I don't
take any out of the property goes back
into our business so about 8 grams of
the last month so that's from deal
sourcing and the passive on the
properties yes yeah and that's really
important because when you take money
out of the equation doors open because
everything changes because you focus on
your own development and you focus on
you know everybody else oh why ever
there's a reason why they're doing this
and when you focus on why you want to do
this more successful relationships
become good friends that was one of my
goals honestly when I went to the crash
course is my brother the first when you
walked out because when I came to the
crash course I wasn't expecting you to
be there I was expecting the video and
you turned up and I said to my brother
I'm gonna be friends with him and that
became one of my goals because you know
I saw the passion in you and I just
wanted to be around that I do I'm
ecstatic with myself because you know it
just goes to show that nothing's on
reachable with you I kept showing up and
taking action yeah cuz you know and when
I go to any of you training courses and
I say this to all the people I meet
there as far as I'm concerned it's me
and you yeah and there might be people
in there in the break that I talk to but
while she'll present and there's me and
you so if you ask a question and the
answer is as far as I'm concerned it's
me and you yeah so yeah
thought out but I get that you know as
well as me because I know there's a lot
within the economy though you're friends
with and you're one of the main rival
backstop you are in your ask the
questions which is just insane people
move on from a student to solicit more
appear now she's incredibly they have
not been in the episode on women so much
and you really think any year but you
know you must have got twenty years
experience of a property investor and
I'm thinking you know you've got one
years experience those around twenty
times over
you've been behind yeah but you've done
so much the lease options joint that
she's embraced honor to pay two
motorbikes that's why we furbish we
finances their packaging
you've really been immersing yourself in
it you've been giving to pretty much
every crash course you know the stuff be
just come for thee for the relationships
and the excitement and then the growth
and which is incredible but if you wanna
get my attention which is what you've
done is take action and get results
sometimes people message me in the same
all of us working on this or what each
of us and it's not working in the global
problem stuff other business because I'm
interested because I am repulsed by
negativity I'm repulsed by I have people
in my team the deal negativity but
anyway of whateleys happen look what I'm
attracted to
its success and when he was not being
successful only invest only investment
property on investing people when I
missed my time
people they appear on the Academy people
would take action but for me that's me
saying I'm getting a return on
investment my advice take my time even
to date crash was for free and now I'm
seeing a return because that person
successful operation now what I wanted
to do is I want to do this more into
those people because I'm no I'll get in
return the [ __ ] the ones the motives
so uninteresting speaking I was totally
uninterested suppose them trying get my
attention by learning Australian what do
we I'm so uninterested I'm interested in
people and taking actions I'm actually
doing it now I want to make time with
them because you do so much that's why I
buy I let's go drink all right come on
to this dinner come on out to me so Matt
Robert Kiyosaki keeps okay and did you
pay for that
no that was all courtesy of yourself
right because I'm just like I thought
meeting Robert Kiyosaki and I wanna
bring some friends
hey do you want to come you don't really
say but you're right and you do you seek
them people up and even I do it now when
you when I see people's faces all the
time and I know you and you seek them
out and yeah exactly that's exactly
right that's what happened with yourself
and I you know you sort me out because I
was taking actually it's fantastic yeah
I think the most important thing is that
you know I I can doubt myself an awful
lot and when I take that away and stop
doubting myself and just start taking
action then you know I do a lot more
because I'm very analytical about what I
do and I'm very focused on even the
things I say and then actually it's just
about all take action first and worry
about it after yes and I think just
having that slight shift of mindset is
is absolutely massive actually
and worry about a half sari most people
worry about things that should be
because about this will be assurance as
this isn't the same thing you know there
speak to it you just got to get out
there and do it take action and figure
out love that so okay
make it about a friend of mine in
poverty been in the game of a year
second time on winners Wednesday talk to
us about your advice watch news that
just think you do I'm gonna hear what
your well I want to be in that chair
like what's your advice I think my best
piece of advice is nothing is
unattainable when people start in
property they think they have to go this
very pyramid route of you know your
foundation of by to that rent service
accommodation and an etc etc that's not
always the case
just be careful about what you do it but
if you see something then you can pursue
it with a joint venture partner so yes
it's right about building the
foundations and going off words but you
can actually reach the something at the
top by using somebody else's skills and
experience and leverages somebody else I
think that's absolutely important
because there are a lot of people
there's a lot of people in this industry
now that are so worried to start because
they think everything's very saturated
they think they can't do it but if you
do something different and step out then
people will notice you and people will
seek you out and they'll support you
some people some people
and then I'll ask them to come on the
news when Zach share that story with us
so don't want it because I think I don't
want to because I don't want to give
away my secrets so firstly I want to
wanted you to look for commander Kaname
26 secondly sometimes people come on
but then when they gonna start making
eight nine ten grand a month and then
killing it then you can't get all of
them that's the truth of it
people forget where they come from and
then I'll invest them in and they'll
become successful within they disappear
and there's some people that I came all
Windows Wednesday before I've been come
on again because they'll be too busy
they're traveling they do nothing you
know and I'm not judging this because
right but I just love it when people
continue inspiring me will continue
share and continue that would be blessed
another thing of my scenes with us which
I really wish it more about you so and
who knows
what's a year CAD amis been fantastic
because I've built so many relationships
there and and well like you already said
James and I are working together now I
didn't have that relationship with him
six months ago
yeah and now we've got an extremely
successful business that we're working
together on and we're doing some
absolutely fantastic things I cannot
wait to share with you that's amazing so
we've got the crash course which is free
two days all starts with vegetables
right all starts at the crack if you
like that and you love the crap schools
and your limos only have the Academy
which is 12 volts which is mentoring
coaching training the whole kaboodle
success dinners one going mind blown
yeah and I said it builds on the
knowledge of the crash course and gives
you the really in-depth detail on all
the specific strategies yeah so let's
just start with the crash course and
he's going to blow you away folks and if
you drop a comment I want you to kind
what was the key thing that actually
said that you're like that was worth
watching the video the best point drop
in the comments what don't you say you
like best and also who you want to see
on wins wins it once you know that we've
been selling
but thank you sir for watching next week
everybody time we share subscribe
[Music]